tha
pendant à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat le gouvernement a donc
décidé de reconduire guillaume pepy à la
tête de la sncf pour un nouveau mandat
de cinq ans pendant ces cinq années
guillaume pepy devra mettre en oeuvre la
réforme ferroviaire voulue par le
gouvernement et qui vise à unifier au
sein d'un même pôle public la sncf et
les entités au gestionnaire du réseau
ferroviaire
mais avant cela sa nomination doit
recevoir le feu vert des députés mais
aussi des sénateurs c'est pour cela
qu'il auditionne guillaume pepy 54 ans
qui est entré en 1988 à la sncf et qui
dirige cette société depuis 2007 tout de
suite donc son audition bonne après midi
à tous mes chers collègues bonjour merci
de votre présence
un certain nombre de nos collègues ils
arriveront au fur et à mesure qu'ils
vont rejoindre la capitale puisque
aujourd'hui 19 mars d'un certain nombre
de manifestations partout alors nous
sommes vous le savez réunis aujourd'hui
pour l'application d'une procédure que
nous connaissons très bien dans cette
commission puisque ça fait quand même un
grand nombre d'auditions que nous venons
de faire et qui sont en application du
5e l'année à de l'article 13 de la
constitution et à ce titre là nous
devons procéder à l'audition de monsieur
guillaume pepy que je savais que nous
accueillons candidat désigné aux
fonctions de président de la sncf cette
nomination par décret en conseil des
ministres ne peut en effet intervenir
qu'après l'audition du candidat devant
les commissions compétentes de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
audition qui devait être suivi d'un vote
les modalités de cette audition et du
vote ont été précisées par la loi
organique du 23 juillet 2010 et la loi
ordinaire dans la même date
il est ainsi prévu que l'audition et
public
elle est également ouverte à la presse à
l'issue de cette audition genre
accompagnerait monsieur pépy demanderai
aux personnes extérieures de bien
vouloir quitter la scène
là afin que nous puissions procéder au
vote qui se déroulera à bulletins
secrets comme le prévoit l'article 19
bis de notre règlement je vous rappelle
qu'il ne peut y avoir deux délégations
de vote que le dépouillement doit être
effectuée simultanément à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat
je fonds je vous confirme que
l'assemblée nationale procédera à
l'audition de monsieur pépy apprennent à
17 heures enfin je vous rappelle qu'en
application de l'article 13 de la
constitution
il ne peut être procédé à cette
nomination si l'addition des votes
négatifs de chaque commission
représenter au moins trois cinquièmes
des suffrages exprimés dans les deux
copains voilà pour le rappel du cadre de
notre audition et bien sûr maintenant je
pense que il est inutile que nous
fassions rappel du parcours et du cv de
monsieur pépy que nous connaissons bien
tous et que nous avons déjà reçu bien
sûr ici au sénat je crois que donc on va
tous être directement très intéressé par
ce qui va me dire bien sûr puisque il
postule à sa succession et donc nous
sommes évidemment très curieux de savoir
si donc une fois qu'il aura pu faire le
bilan
son précédent mandat il nous parle
surtout de l'avenir
et bien sûr cette cette feuille de route
qu'il a certainement déjà dans sa tête
qui nous intéresse alors quelque sorte
on aimerait savoir comment vous
envisagez notamment la réforme du
secteur ferroviaire
la préparation de l'ouverture à la
concurrence du marché ferroviaire
européenne qui désormais acquise pour
comment vous comptez effectivement aussi
améliorer la rentabilité de l'entreprise
condition déterminante au problème de la
résorption de la dette qui s'accroît
alors qui aujourd'hui représente plus
d'un milliard d'euros par an je rappelle
d'ailleurs que cette dette ferroviaire
atteint au total près de 40 milliards si
l'on cumule la dette de la sncf
la dette des réflexes autre question
avez vous l'intention de revoir le
périmètre de l'entreprise qui recouvre
de nombreuses activités et pas loin de
900 filiales
quel sera l'avenir des trains
d'équilibré du territoire régi par une
convention entre l'état et la sncf qui
je le rappelle arrivera à son terme à la
fin de l'année comment voyez vous
l'évolution des relations entre la sncf
et les régions
vaste problème où en sont vos projets de
régionalisation et de l'organisation de
votre entreprise dont vous aviez
beaucoup parler notre douleur de votre
dernière audition bien sûr que comptez
vous proposer pour redresser l'activité
du fret de la sncf vous savez qu'au
titre de notre compétence aménagement
territoire c'est un problème sur lequel
nous avons tous des idées nous avons
tous des problèmes alors je demande à
mes collègues mais même si c'est un très
gros effort de garder ces questions pour
une autre audition je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons surtout
notre mission est de surtout écoutez
monsieur pépy au titre de sa candidature
et donc il n'est pas interdit de poser
quelques questions mais c'est pas le
sujet essentiel de cette audition je
sais que c'est un gros effort que nous
vous demandons mais il faut avant tout
assurer l'audition pour le vote qui
s'ensuit ensuite donc vous avez parlé
évidemment de la mise en place d'un
cadre social harmonisé dans le cadre
probable du roman de la sncf infra et
les réflexes
est-ce qu'il est toujours d'actualité et
enfin on oublie souvent et vous l'aviez
aussi beaucoup peut rappeler que votre
groupe est très présent à
l'international et donc quelle est votre
stratégie à cet égard donc voilà autant
de sujets qui aujourd'hui vont vous
permettre de nous donner à la fois votre
vision
et puis je n'en doute pas faire émerger
cette motivation qui vous anime que nous
connaissons bien pour postuler pour une
nouvelle mandature à ce poste très
important voilà monsieur pépy vous avez
la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
veux saluer toutes les sénatrices et
sénateurs présents et vous dire d'emblée
que c'est évidemment un très grand
honneur de me présenter devant vous cet
après midi pour cette audition
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir plusieurs
auditions dans la haute assemblée
celle ci est un peu particulière vous
vous en avez rappelé le contexte et je
veux vraiment souligner que la sncf
étant aujourd'hui une des toutes
premières entreprises publiques
nationales
le fait de se voir proposer la direction
de cette entreprise c'est évidemment une
responsabilité très particulière et à il
ya un très grand honneur
je pense que dans cette responsabilité
le lien avec les grands élus avec les
parlementaires le lien que les autorités
organisatrices a une dimension tout à
fait particulière sur sur les 34
milliards de chiffre d'affaires de la
sncf il y en a la moitié qui sont faits
aujourd'hui dans du service public
contractualiser avec les régions la
région ile-de-france l'état et d'autres
collectivités agglomération commune et
donc au fond la moitié de l'activité de
la sncf est directement relié aux
décisions politiques prises par les élus
et les collectivités ayant dit ça comme
vous me invité monsieur le président je
propose de prendre la parole de 10 à 15
minutes pour répondre aux deux séries de
questions que vous aviez soulevé c'est à
dire d'une part dans quel état
aujourd'hui et l entreprise je suis
évidemment le plus mal placé pour
m'exprimer sur mon bilan pense que ça
s'est plutôt faux parlementaire et à
d'autres de le faire mais en revanche je
peux donner quelques éléments sur la
situation de l'entreprise
et puis évidemment vous dire quelle est
la vision d'avenir que je propose
mais c'est une vision que je propose car
aussi bien avec le gouvernement qu'avec
le parlement il ya des moments précis où
ces propositions seront examinées
challenge et amendé dans tel ou tel sens
donc je ne parle que de mes propositions
donc pour être court et laisser le
maximum de place aux échanges
quelques mots sur la situation d'abord
la carte d'identité
cette entreprise a beaucoup changé
d'envergure
elle est sans doute aujourd'hui la 17e
ou la 18e entreprises françaises avec un
chiffre d'affaires de 34 milliards
nous sommes le numéro deux mondial des
services de mobilité le numéro un c'est
la deutsche bahn et nous avons 250 mille
salariés 150 mille cheminots et cent
mille salariés qui exercent leurs
activités dans d'autres secteurs que le
rail
nous avons les trois quarts de notre
activité en france et un quart de notre
activité en europe et dans le monde
et puis pour donner quelques indications
notre marge opérationnelle est de
l'ordre de 9 et demi pour cent il
faudrait qu'elle soit supérieure à 11%
pour que nous soyons entre guillemets
confortable donc il nous reste de la
marge à conquérir
nous avons évidemment résultat positif
qui a été cette année de 700 millions
d'euros ce qui a permis de verser un
dividende à l'état 2 2
100 millions d'euros c'est la cinquième
année consécutive que nous versons un
dividende à l'état et d'autre part nous
avons versé un dividende salarial à
chacun des cent cinquante mille salariés
cheminots de 364 euros
mais ce que je retiens dans cette carte
d'identité c'est plutôt le montant des
investissements
on a investi ces cinq dernières années
13 milliards d'euros c'est à dire que
contrairement à beaucoup d'entreprises
qui réduisent leurs investissements en
période de crise nous nous avons
augmenté grâce au plan de modernisation
du réseau grâce aux régions et à l'achat
de nouveaux trains
et cette année 2013 c'est un pic
historique d'investissement on atteindra
2,5 milliards d'euros d'investissements
voilà quelques bons donc de la carte
d'identité
peut-être un petit mot sur nos trois
métiers principaux que vous avez repris
président le fret la logistique les
voyageurs et la gestion des réseaux
alors sur fret et logistique c'est un
métier de 9 milliards d'euros
sur les 33 qui comporte
c'était la mission que j'avais reçu dans
mon premier mandat la création d'un
champion français de la logistique au
plan international
ce champion s'appelle geodis c'est le
quatrième européen ce qui est
intéressant dans cette position c'est
que les trois premiers sont allemands et
qu'il avait été demandé que la france
est un champion de la logistique au
service des industriels français
donc nous avons rempli cette mission
il ya eu deux crises importantes en 2009
et en 2012 sur les volumes qui font que
la rentabilité n'est pas aujourd'hui
suffisante et qu'il faut donc que nous
reprenions là dessus de l'amélioration
de nos résultats opérationnels au
passage ce champion de la logistique
s'appelle geodis par exemple fait 1
milliards de facturations à l'industrie
automobile française et européenne nous
sommes donc le bras armé de l'industrie
automobile européenne deuxième métier
toujours dans le fret et la logistique
le métier du transport ferroviaire de
marchandises ça représente 2 milliards
d'euros
comme vous l'avez indiqué monsieur le
président l'environnement a complètement
changé arrivée de la concurrence en 2007
cette concurrence a plutôt été un échec
parce qu'elle n'a pas été correctement
préparé et parce qu'elle s'exerce dans
des conditions qui sont absolument pas
équitable au total la part du fret
il ya dix neuf opérateurs en france nous
sommes un des 19 le plus important mais
nous sommes un des 19 a décru ces
dernières années et donc nous sommes
devant deux défis le premier défi c'est
de repartir dans le développement
j'imagine qu'on aura l'occasion d'en
parler il faut pour ça des
infrastructures dédiées
il faut pour cela des conditions de
concurrence loyale et il faut pour ça un
cadre social qu'ils soient harmonisés et
puis la deuxième condition c'est les
efforts propres de la sncf pour
s'améliorer changer son organisation
être plus souple être plus réactives
mieux correspondre aux attentes des
clients
on a des indices positifs par exemple la
satisfaction des clients de fret sncf a
augmenté de 10 points
ces deux dernières années on est loin
des légendes qui courait sur les vagues
ont perdu les trains qui n'arrivent
jamais les délais gigantesque aile et
les vitesses très très basse des trains
de fret deuxième métier de deuxième
grande famille de métier le transport de
voyageurs
là on a je pense collectivement une
vraie satisfaction c'est notre pays la
france est le deuxième consommateur de
trait en europe à leur champion toutes
catégories les suisses mais juste
derrière les suisses ceux des européens
qui prennent le plus de train c'est les
français et au plan mondial
nous sommes troisièmes et japonais les
suisses les français et donc pour
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens le train
c'est absolument vital et la
modernisation du train c'est une
priorité absolue
là dessus je pense que chacun a senti
que les priorités de la sncf avait
beaucoup changé ces dernières années on
n'est plus dans tout tgv on est passés
avec une priorité absolue qui sont
l'amélioration des services publics de
la vie quotidienne ceux qui sont
utilisés par presque quatre millions de
français tous
jour sur le territoire et qui permettent
d'aller à l'école au collège ou au
travail et qui sont au service de tous
je pense qu'on est assez fiers ces
dernières années d'avoir réussi avec nos
collègues de rff
la grande bascule horaire qui a eu lieu
l'année dernière puis cette année mais
nous avons un nouveau défi gens diraient
quelques mots qui est le la gestion du
gigantesque montant de travaux qui est
une bonne chose qui aujourd'hui ont lieu
sur le territoire
je vous le disais il ya un instant
priorité aux transports de la vie
quotidienne en ile-de-france
modernisation des rer en région
modernisation des ter en partenariat
avec les régions qui ont fait un effort
gigantesque 2,7 milliards d'euros
d'achats de matériels neufs
vous l'avez citer les trains d'équilibré
du territoire une convention qui a été
signée il ya maintenant deux ans nous
avons proposé au gouvernement de la
prolonger d'un an pour que nous
puissions réfléchir et les pouvoirs
publics et l'entreprise sur l'avenir de
ses trains d'équilibré du territoire qui
sont des trains extrêmement important
puisque ce sont ceux qui desservent la
plupart des villes moyennes
enfin dernier mot sur les transports de
voyageurs les gars après un rapport
remarqué de fabienne keller une loi ou
rtf qui a été adoptée dans ses murs en
2009 nous avons créé une activité de
gars bien isolé bien identifiés et nous
avons un projet c'est que ces gars
soient des gardes multimodal donc de
tous les modes de transport et pas
seulement des gares du train et d'autre
part que ce soit des nouveaux centres
villes c'est à dire qu'au fond on cesse
d'avoir ces zones en mauvais état un peu
abandonné ces délaissés ferroviaire pour
remettre des projets d'aménagement
d'importance voilà je dis un tout petit
mot pour terminer de notre métier de
réseau le réseau ferroviaire français
ses trente-quatre mille kilomètres
c'est le deuxième réseau d'europe après
le réseau allemand c'est un réseau qui
était en très mauvais état qui est
aujourd'hui en pleine modernisation on
est au milieu du gué
pour vous donnez mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs une indication et à cette
année 1000 chantiers
cette année sur le réseau
et il y à 1000 km de voies classiques
qui vont être entièrement rénové c'est
là encore un pic historique on était à
moins de 300 il ya dix ans donc on est à
foix iii en terme de travaux de
rénovation sur le réseau deux derniers
mots pour terminer ce tout petit
panorama de la situation actuelle un mot
sur les personnels l'emploi le dialogue
social les conditions de travail les
effectifs sont aujourd'hui stabilisé
grâce à la dynamique de l'activité cette
année en 2013 on est le troisième
recruteur de france
nous en avons la possibilité plus de
10000 postes à pourvoir avec un accent
mis sur les zones urbaines sensibles 15
% des recrutements et un accent mis
aussi sur évidemment les emplois
d'avenir
les discussions en cours sur les
contrats de génération est notre
vocation vis-à-vis des handicapés
vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des populations
les plus fragiles pour l'accès à
l'emploi sur le dialogue social la loi
sur le service minimum votée il ya
quelques années aujourd'hui n'est plus
contesté à l'intérieur de l'entreprise
elle a fixé le point d'équilibré entre
le droit de grève et le droit au
transport fonctionne plutôt bien
et quant au dialogue social on signe des
accords à la sncf y compris à
l'unanimité on en a signé cette année 5
et le niveau de conflit niveau de grève
est au plus bas niveau en 2012 depuis
une dizaine d'années le dernier point je
voulais souligner c'est notre rôle de
champion industriel
nous sommes heureux que au fond il ya
une prise de conscience que l'industrie
ferroviaire française et les exploitants
et l'ingénierie c'est un des points
forts de notre pays la france est sur le
podium de tête de cette industrie avec
les japonais les allemands 1 2 3 c'est
nous et dès qu'on quitte la france
le ferroviaire français est attendu sur
tous les projets que ce soit les projets
de trains régionaux de tramway de métros
de trains à grande vitesse et nous avons
repris là dessus une fonction un peu de
chef d'equipe du ferroviaire français on
chasse en meute
on se balade en europe et dans le monde
dans une concurrence très difficile avec
des japonais les coréens les chinois les
allemands les espagnols pour vendre les
savoir faire français
il nous semble que ça c'est une partie
très importante de notre notre mission
avant de dire quelques mots des
perspectives je veux dire ce sur quoi je
n'ai pas réussi ou en tout cas auquel au
moins quelques éléments sur lequel j'ai
pas réussi un le fret
la situation est à l'évidence
insatisfaisante la qualité de service a
progressé je voulais dit mais si on veut
développer le fret ferroviaire français
les 19 entreprises qui en font il faut
se donner des conditions qui pour le
moment n'ont pas été totalement réunies
et je considère là dessus que c'est pas
encore un succès 2 dans la relation avec
les voyageurs l'information reste un
point faible et c'est un point faible
parce que c'est une course de vitesse
entre les outils modernes que chacun
possède et puis les circuits
d'information qui sont beaucoup plus
lents et qui sont beaucoup plus
incertain et donc nous avons une
bataille là dessus à reprendre et à
gagner pour que chacun de nos quatre
millions de voyageurs par jour
ce sont aussi bien renseignés par la
sncf sur ce qui se passe qu'il est
aujourd'hui renseigner sur la météo sur
l'actualité courante
c'est un sacré défi mais il faut se
donner ce niveau-là d'exigence et puis
le troisième point sur lequel je pense
que nous n'avons pas encore suffisamment
progressé c'est l'ile-de-france
je pense que notre pays a tardé à
prendre les bonnes décisions
elles ont été prises ces dernières
années et il ya encore quelques semaines
par les décisions annoncées par le
premier ministre mais le retard a été
accumulée depuis vingt ou trente ans et
il va falloir mettre les bouchées
doubles pour que les transports de l'île
de france soit au niveau de ce qu'ils
sont dans les régions et il faut assumer
me semble-t-il le fait que l'endroit où
on est malheureusement le moins bien
transporter en france et dans la région
capitale
par rapport aux autres régions ayant dit
ça je voulais comme vous m'avez invité
président dira
comment des perspectives en ré insistant
sur le fait que ce sont des propositions
qui n'ont pas encore reçu l'aval ni du
gouvernement ni de la représentation
nationale
il me semble qui a pour les cinq
prochaines années trois grands enjeux
le premier vous l'avez cité c'est la
réussite de la réforme ferroviaire
cette réforme du système ferroviaire
elle a été lancée par des assises qui
avait été initiée par nathalie kosciusko
morizet par des états généraux qui avait
été lancé par jacques auxiette puis
repris par le gouvernement avec un
travail qui s'effectue aujourd'hui sous
l'autorité de frédéric cuvillier et une
mission d' expertise de jean louis
bianco
c'est ma responsabilité
me semble-t-il de réussir la réforme que
vous adopterez au parlement
la réussir ça veut dire améliorer la
qualité de service ça veut dire faire
mieux pour moins cher et ça veut dire
avoir un service public dans notre pays
des transports qui soit un service
public exemplaire qu'on puisse par
ailleurs exporter il est trop tôt pour
dire encore quel sera le contenu précis
de la réforme
ce dont je veux vous assurer c'est que
nous ne sommes parfaitement conscients
que cette réforme du système ferroviaire
suppose que la sncf sache se remettre en
cause elle même qu'elle saisisse cette
chance pour être plus compétitive plus
efficace plus réactive par rapport aux
attentes des voyageurs et des chargeurs
bref que ça soit l'occasion cette
réforme du ferroviaire de franchir une
étape de modernisation de la sncf
deuxième enjeu continuer notre
développement dans une période qui va
être je n'ose plus dire le mot crise
parce que je pense que pendant les trois
ou quatre prochaines années
c'est une économie qui croît moins vite
mais il faut vivre avec cette économie
là et saisir des opportunités là dessus
au fond nos enjeux sont les suivants il
faut certainement qu'on soit capable de
baisser nos coûts pour pouvoir baisser
nos prix la sncf ça doit être pour tous
c'est une entreprise qui doit avoir des
prix qui sont acceptables par toute la
population puisque nous sommes propriété
collective est la seule solution pour
pouvoir baisser nos prix c'est de
baisser nos coûts et donc nous avons
commencé à travailler systématiquement
deux plans de performances
un premier plan de performance
industrielle pour mieux utiliser nos
équipements mieux utiliser nos trains et
l'enjeu il est probable mort aux
alentours d'un milliard et demi à deux
milliards d'efficacité industrielle
d'ici les quatre ou cinq ans qui
viennent
le deuxième enjeu toujours en termes de
performance c'est la capacité que nous
avons à réduire nos frais de
fonctionnement nos frais de siège
nous sommes les héritiers d'une
entreprise qui était à l'époque assez
administrative qui s'est beaucoup
transformé mais il faut que les
responsabilités soient sur le terrain
que la marge de manoeuvre est
l'initiative soit laissé aux
responsables locaux et que ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui de corporate c'est à
dire les l'ensemble des sièges n'écrase
pas le fonctionnement de l'entreprise
donc là aussi un plan de performance qui
est de l'ordre de 700 millions d'euros
pour faire en sorte que la richesse de
la sncf puisse être utilisé près du
terrain et pas seulement dans des
fonctions support voilà un mood donc sur
ce contexte économique non sans avoir
rebondi sur ce que disait le président
l'international c'est 25%
ça doit être de l'ordre
je pense de 30% à 33% d'ici cinq ans
la bagarre a commencé nous étions il ya
quelques jours au brésil avec les
autorités politiques françaises en inde
en russie
nous allons prochainement en chine nous
allons prochainement au maroc
il est clair que tous les pays émergents
souhaitent des transports publics de
qualité pour faire face à la saturation
à l'asphyxié
aux enjeux de l'aménagement du
territoire et que la sncf a un rôle à
jouer avec l'équipe de france pour
répondre à cette attente la et donc il
faut absolument que nous conservions
notre podium deux premiers ou deuxièmes
ex-aequo comme pays qui sait faire du
transport public en toute sécurité en
efficacité et ouvert à tous je
terminerai en disant un petit mot sur le
projet stratégique
c'est mon troisième point pour ce qui
est du mandat ce projet stratégique il
est en cours d'élaboration
nous sommes en train de le bâtir et nous
souhaitons le mettre en débat dans
l'entreprise est également avec les élus
et les responsables politiques dans les
quatre ou cinq mois qui viennent de
telle sorte que ce projet ne soit pas un
projet venu du haut mais au contraire un
projet qui soit construit et bâti à
partir des attentes des exigences et des
questions qui mobilise nos parties
prenantes
ce qu'on peut dire ce qu'on peut-on dire
peut-être c'est trois ou quatre choses
d'abord le train est formidable mais si
on veut avoir plus de voyageurs dans le
train il faut convaincre
c'est une évidence des automobilistes
c'est pas les utilisateurs du train
qu'il faut convaincre ce sont les
automobilistes pour convaincre les
automobilistes
il faut être une alternative crédible à
la détention individuelle de la voiture
automobile
donc il faut proposer des solutions de
bout en bout
il faut proposer de combiner les modes
de transport entre eux avec le
stationnement avec les transports
urbains et être aussi attractif que la
voiture c'est à dire flexible aussi
personnaliser à voir là la formation de
la meilleure qualité pour convaincre des
automobilistes que le transport
collectif est une alternative crédible
donc le projet que je porte devant vous
c'est un projet réellement dont le train
est la colonne vertébrale mais qui a
pour ambition d'être une alternative à
l'automobile dans le domaine du fret
ferroviaire
notre projet c'est réellement de
s'appuyer sur tout ce qu'on appelle le
multimodal
le multimodal c'est prendre les
marchandises dans les ports c'est être
capable d'avoir des autoroutes
ferroviaires
c'est être capable de faire des trains
longs en europe qui traverse l'europe
voire qui permettent d'aller vers l'asie
ça se fera un jour avec des trains de
très longs parcours et c'est aussi être
capable de faire du transport de fret de
proximité dans les opérateurs
ferroviaires de proximité bref c'est
d'être une sorte de multi spécialiste du
transport moderne de marchandises il est
clair qu'il ya une zone de pertinence du
fret
on peut pas faire des trains par exemple
de bois sur 200 km ou sur ou transporter
des marchandises pondéreuses sur 50 km
là la route et malheureusement entre
guillemets rennes mais il faut que nous
soyons capables de travailler tous les
marchés qui sont accessibles au fret
ferroviaire en france et en europe
enfin le troisième troisième élément
c'est la préparation de l'avenir vous
l'avais dit la concurrence à l'heure où
nous parlons
elle arrive en 2018 2019 selon les
règles européennes c'est-à-dire dans
cinq ans si la sncf entreprise nationale
veut être à la hauteur des enjeux il
faut que nous soyons beaucoup plus
compétitifs qu'aujourd'hui que nous
ayons un cadre social modernisé négocier
et il faut que nous ayons mis l'ensemble
de nos produits en capacité de résister
à la concurrence la concurrence viendra
principalement d'opérateurs ferroviaires
européens y aura quelques nouveaux
entrants mais c'est des métiers ou très
capitalistique donc il faut mettre
beaucoup beaucoup de milliards pour être
capable de faire du chemin de fer donc
ça viendra probablement de nos collègues
italiens de nos que légalement de nos
collègues suisses de nos collègues
espagnols
donc là encore il ya une préparation qui
doit s'accélérer pendant les années à
venir pour être en situation je
terminerais d'un mot en disant quelques
convictions de méthode
la première conviction c'est que s'il
faut accélérer la modernisation de la
sncf il faut que les salariés soient en
confiance on pourra pas faire sans la
confiance de 250 mille salariés
la réforme qui va être proposé dans
quelques mois je l'espère au parlement
sera un élément clé de cette confiance
parce que ça donne une perspective et
que les salariés ont besoin de cette
perspective le rail en france est en
gros un million de personnes
deux cent cinquante mille personnes à la
sncf plus les familles les ayants droit
les retraités deuxième condition de de
réussite
le fait que la sncf sache elle même se
décentraliser baisser son centre de
gravité
louis gallois de mes prédécesseurs
disait de cette formule connue la sncf
ses larbins plus la discipline
une formule 1 peut imager mais qui
voulait dire que tout remonte et donc
aujourd'hui il faut qu'on soit capable
de fonctionner beaucoup plus proche des
élus beaucoup plus proche des clients ce
mouvement est engagé
enfin la troisième condition pour
réussir
c'est ce que nous avons appelé la
co-construction la co-construction ça
signifie que les projets de la sncf
doivent être des projets ouverts des
projets semi-finis des projets itératif
des projets qui ne prétendent pas au
moment où ils sortent être optimisé m en
quelque sorte mis sur la table comme
éléments au débat pour être améliorés
amende est modifié c'est un gros
changement culturel
on passe d'un point de vue d'ingénieurs
entre guillemets qui prétendrait avoir
trouver la meilleure solution à une
proposition faite par l'entreprise
publique qui est mise en débat pour être
débattu et amendé et optimisé et cette
façon de coûts construire les réponses
me semble être la façon la plus moderne
et la façon du futur voilà ce que je
voulais dire si vous aussi vous acceptez
monsieur le président que je je je
m'arrête là si je le caricature le
projet que je porte est un projet d'une
sncf qui serait la sncf des connexions
en quelque sorte une façon de connecter
les différents modes de transport avec
le système ferroviaire au centre mais un
système qui est ouvert aux autres modes
de transport pour pouvoir conquérir
davantage de parts de marché et une sncf
modeste et en même temps qui a
l'ambition d'être un opérateur
un expert est aussi quelque part un
architecte des systèmes de mobilité dans
notre pays merci monsieur le président
merci donc vous pressez exposé très
clair je donne la parole bien sûr mes
collègues en commençant par monsieur
michel teston merci monsieur le
président comme je devrais m'investir
assez fortement prochainement sur le
projet de gouvernance ferroviaire
j'espère coup accepterait que je sois un
peu plus long que ne l'avait prévu le
président mal en abordant quelques
questions qui ont d'ailleurs déjà été
largement évoquée par le président pepy
je le président malgré la crise qui a
fortement impacté le secteur ferroviaire
les résultats de la sncf sont
satisfaisants vous avez vous même cité
le chiffre de 34 milliards d'euros comme
un chiffre d'affaires de l'entreprise
et quand on compare ce chiffre
d'affaires à celui que vous avez connu
en 2008 il a progressé de 40 %
principalement mais pas seulement en
raison de l'intégration les comptes de
la filiale keolis et le résultat vous
l'avez indiqué 700 millions d'euros
cette année
avec le versement de dividendes à l'état
ferait pas d'autres commentaires et la
dette qui à ma connaissance devrait
baisser cette année mais là il faudra
couper chez nous le préciser d'un
milliard d'euros ce qui fait qu'elles
pourraient descendre au dessous de 7
milliards d'euros alors cette réussite
de la sncf
eh bien elle est à mettre à votre actif
je le dis sans détour
mais ceci ne doit pas dissimuler tout de
même
une situation inquiétante du système
ferroviaire français et des perspectives
incertaines pour pour la sncf
alors je dirai un mot d'abord du système
ferroviaire et ensuite quelques
questions sur bien sûr l'avenir de la
sncf
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président pépy le système ferroviaire
une dette de 32 milliards d'euros qui
croient mécaniquement chaque année de
1,4 milliard d'euros pour pour les
annuités de la dette
c'est rff qui supportent pour l'instant
cette nette deuxième élément important
que vous avez aussi évoqué la séparation
entre rff et la sncf a été cause de
lourdeurs de redondance d'une complexité
très importante et probablement aussi
d'une majoration sensible des dépenses
dans la gestion des infrastructures et
donc il convient effectivement de
réussir la réforme ferroviaire
en créant ce gestionnaire
d'infrastructure unifiée qui sera donc
rattachée à la sncf en regroupant rff à
la direction des circulations
ferroviaires et sncf infra et le
ministre des transports nous a confié
cette mission de réussir cette réforme
ferroviaire qui est une mission délicate
est essentiel parce que il faudra
qu'elle soit je parle de la réforme
efficace et qu'elle ne vienne pas
heurter un certain nombre les
dispositions du quatrième paquet
ferroviaire de l'union européenne qui
est en cours donc actuellement d'examen
et qui interpelle quand même largement
celles et ceux qui suivent de près ce
secteur j'en viens à la deuxième partie
de mon intervention sur l'avenir de la
sncf elle-même et son rôle dans le
soutien dans le respect des règles de la
concurrence de l'industrie ferroviaire
française
j'évoquerai quelques questions 4
brièvement
premièrement la nécessité de conclure
nouveaux clients vous l'avez vous même
évoqué je veux dire un mot sur le choix
vous avez fait du tgv
bakou le we go qui est une réponse
effectivement à l'érosion du profil
d'activité tgv puisqu'on a pu constater
au cours des dernières années que cette
activité a vu ses marges s'éroder
je pense que il des bus répondent à la
même logique en ce qui concerne donc le
transport routier de voyageurs
je sais pas si vous avez d'autres
projets de cette nature pour conquérir
de nouveaux clients puisque vous l'avez
dit vous-même c'est une de vos priorités
deuxième question dans la perspective
d'une ouverture totale à la concurrence
en 2019 en 2025 alors je ne fais pas
partie des demandeurs je le rappelle
avec force mais pour à tour y échapper
comment comment parvenir un cadre social
commun ou harmoniser sans lequel la
concurrence ne peut pas être loyal
donc ça c'est une c'est une crainte
parce que il faut pas se trouver dans
une situation que dans le fret où on a
ouvert à la concurrence sans se
préoccuper du cadre social harmonisé et
donc répondre à cette question me paraît
nécessité de traiter les questions
d'organisation et de règlement du
travail mais sans toucher au statut et
donc c'est là que la tâche est difficile
une autant plus intéressante troisième
question c'est sur le quatrième paquet
ferroviaire sites antiques qui voit le
jour il a prévu d'autoriser le système
dit de l'open access lors de l'ouverture
totale à la concurrence des services
furent vers leur explique
pour celles et ceux qui pratique pas
quotidiennement je dirais les revues
ferroviaire et qui ne s'intéressent pas
directement à tout ce qui a trait au
ferroviaire le plan d'accès ça veut dire
que n'importe quel opérateur pourrait
venir librement sur des lignes rentables
quitte à délaisser complètement des
lignes non rentables
donc monsieur le président êtes vous
prêt à vous mobiliser comme nous sommes
prêts à le faire en nous soutenant
fortement pour obtenir que cette forme
d'accès au réseau qui est très
déstabilisante pour le système
ferroviaire soit définitivement écarté
si on doit aller dans l'ouverture à la
concurrence dans le système du grand
père comme n'en est rien hier le système
des franchises
mais en tout cas pas le système de
l'open access quatrième question
elle porte sur l'industrie ferroviaire
et le lien avec la sncf
je crois que comme le font très bien la
db les airs face les cff ssbb quand les
chemins de fer suisses et les chemins de
fer italiens et allemands donc il faut
que la sncf soutiennent fortement
l'industrie ferroviaire national je le
redis dans le respect bien sûr des
règles de la concurrence
alors vous avez abordé la question des
trains d'équilibré du territoire ou il
me semble que la sncf devrait pour
remplacer les rames tract est constitué
de deux voitures corail qui sont tant
qu'ils sont anciennes s'intéresser aux
nouveaux matériels 1 et 2 niveaux
fabriqués en france par deux
constructeurs qui sont sur le territoire
national ce qui permettait d'ajouter des
commandes à celles qui sont passés par
les régions pour les ter
puisque pour l'instant c'est comment ne
sont pas un niveau très élevé quand ton
matériel à grande vitesse
messam qui convient de confirmer une
commande d'une tranche complémentaire
nous 30 on ira par exemple de matériel à
deux niveaux de niveau actuel de
réfléchir à d'éventuelles commandes à
partir de 2017 d'un futur de niveaux
encore plus capacitaire ne faut pas
oublier pour autant le matériel à un
niveau faute de quoi l'industrie
française devraient abandonner la
fourniture de ce type de matière aux
industries allemandes chinoises
japonaises pour ne citer que ces trois
industries et ce serait d'autant plus
regrettable que quand on regarde les
commandes de trains grande vitesse
certes c'est une niche dans les
commandes ferroviaires mais quand on
regarde dans le monde
les commandes de trains grande vitesse
on s'aperçoit que la grande majorité
devrait commander sont des trains à un
niveau et que le matériel à grande
vitesse français à un niveau si les du
fait de sa structure
je veux pas rentrer dans les détails
techniques mais très légèrement moins
capacitaires que le concurrent allemand
et technologiquement très en avance j
insiste lourdement avec la légèreté la
grande stabilité la rigide
c'est une bonne résistance à
l'avancement et un confort qui sont
propres à une rame entièrement articulé
autant de qualités essentielles qu'il
est absolument nécessaire de prendre en
compte et qui est parfaitement possible
de prendre en compte dans son appel
d'offres alors je termine monsieur le
président en disant voilà un certain
nombre de défis que vous avez à relever
en ce qui me concerne pour relever ces
défis vous avez toute ma confiance
merci monsieur chaire histoire dont
j'encourage vivement mes collègues être
plus concis sinon parce que président
pepy doit partir à 16h30 donc nous
partageons le reste monsieur michel
teston la parole et à francis grignon
merci monsieur le président baho delà
toutes les questions qui ont été
évoquées moi je voudrais poser trois
très précises une question d'actualité
sur la sécurité quand même bien qu'on ne
puisse pas généraliser mais il ne
faudrait pas que ça devienne une
psychose de prendre le train le soir
alors quid de la suge de son
développement des protections diverses
et variées qu'on peut envisager et du
fait de ne pas avoir ne plus avoir dans
certaines régions c'est bien que ça
dépend de la décision des régions mais
de contrôleurs dans les trains par
exemple la deuxième question élites
économiques
quid du de l'avenir du modèle tgv au
delà des lignes qui existe alors je sais
bien que ça ne dépend pas de vous mais
d'abord de la volonté de construire des
infrastructures de rff et donc du
gouvernement
n'empêche que on ne pourra les
construire s'il ya des gens qui prennent
y les trains qui vont sur ses lignes
donc d'un point de vue commercial
comment voyez-vous maintenant le
développement de lignes transversales ou
pas dans notre région sachant que le
modèle tgv a quand même en partie à
cause d'eux des problèmes économiques
et effectivement du mal à progresser et
la troisième question c'est sur la
transparence vous aviez évoqué le
problème de la suisse j'ai beaucoup
analysé ce qui se passait en suisse en
suisse ya pas de concurrence mais y ait
une transparence totale et j'estime que
ces chemins de fer sont certainement les
les plus performants d'europe aussi bien
pour les pouvoirs publics pour les
usagers rapport qualité prix et cetera
donc j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue
sur cette france
france vis-à-vis des régions qui
représentent quand même à travers cette
proximité un chiffre d'affaires
important pour conclure je veux pas
cacher ici le fait que j'étais deux ans
au conseil d'administration de la sncf
et dire que j'ai beaucoup apprécié votre
compétence votre expérience et il suffit
de lire le cv pour le voir mais aussi
votre considération pour l'ensemble des
parties prenantes ainsi que votre
pragmatisme masson marais monsieur le
président vous voulez vous remercier
pour cet exposé très exhaustif nous est
passée tout de même sur deux sujets
assez rapidement je voudrais revenir
dessus
vous n'avez pas de satisfaction des
clients c'est une évidence les médias
sont pas assez facilement et c'est tout
à fait normal de la satisfaction des
clients
donc je comprends que c'est une priorité
moi ce qui m'intéresse beaucoup
aujourd'hui c'est la satisfaction à
l'intérieur chez vos employés pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui tout le monde sait
qu'on a fait des progrès énormes en haut
niveau de la souffrance physique au
travail depuis six décennies la sncf
évidemment et traite à fait
opérationnels et compétentes à ce niveau
mais qu'en est-il la souffrance morale
au travail c'est un sujet aujourd'hui
qui me paraît extrêmement important
parce que même si eux
aujourd'hui vous ne faites pas du tout
partie des organisations qui ont le plus
de problèmes vous avez tout de même eu
depuis quatre ans 22 suicides au travail
sur le lieu de travail et cette année au
mois de janvier vous avez encore une
personne de vote de vos équipes qui
s'est suicidé sur son lieu de travail
or on sait très bien que les nouvelles
orientations de l'organisation des
structures et de gestion des ressources
humaines de la sncf qui est absolument
nécessaire pour être dans l'actualité
ils ont tout pour être opérationnels
entraîne du stress et entraîne beaucoup
de problèmes qui sont des maladies
psychosomatiques et autres mais on sait
très bien que si à l'intérieur de
l'organisation le personnel n'est pas
satisfait et bien c'est l'organisation
qui est en danger
donc je voudrais savoir quels sont les
nouveaux objectifs
comment vous allez étudier ce problème
c'est que vous étudiez déjà en ce moment
mais comment vous allez devenir plus
opérationnels au niveau de la gestion
des ressources humaines de la sncf
et quelle politique vous allez mettre en
place vous avez dit qu'il y avait le
moins de grèves à la sncf depuis dix ans
en pourcentage je ne sais pas si ça
n'est un excellent indicateur de
satisfaction travail des employés dont
je voudrais là dessus qu'on y revienne
peut-être pas aujourd'hui mais en tout
cas c'est une réflexion que vous meniez
au sein de la sncf
merci gérard cornu
oui en écoutant tout à l'heure à michel
teston je me demandais s'ils allaient
pas postuler la présidence de la sncf a
fait je te dire c'est que c'est la
confiance m'a fait remarquer le
président en arrivant dans baby m'a dit
j'aime concurrents de la salle voilà bon
donc on se rejoint oui mais monsieur le
président donc vous êtes là devant la
représentation nationale pour postulait
renouvellement de votre mandat et moi je
vais le dire très clairement votre bilan
est bon et en plus vos perspectives sont
séduisants dont je ne doute pas que la
représentation nationale sera à la fois
récompenser votre bilan et surtout
apprécié les perspectives que vous nous
avez tracée votre bilan est bon à la
fois sur le fond mais aussi et moi je
voudrais je devrais le dire sur la forme
vous n'avez jamais hésité à être très
transparent devant la représentation
nationale ou êtes venus souvent et je
peux vous dire que c'était fortement
appréciée et en plus moi je trouve que
vous venez de décrire finalement où vous
avez les points faibles que vous avez
pas pu dans ce mandat et j'espère que ça
sera pouvoir être résolue dans le
prochain mandat
les points faibles vous avez cité le
fret les relations avec les voyageurs et
et notamment et tout et tout l'ensemble
de l'ile-de-france est sûre sur ses
points faibles vous avez dit par exemple
sur le fret à condition qu'ils aient des
cons du coup conditions de concurrence
loyale je voudrais que vous abordez un
petit peu plus en détails
parce que si vous donner ces conditions
c'est qu'il semblerait qu'il y ait des
concurrences de la concurrence déloyale
donc je voudrais en savoir un petit peu
plus et puis vous avez insisté sur
l'amélioration des services publics de
la vie quotidienne et je me rappelle
lorsque vous êtes venu en commission
vous nous avez explicité que y'a vous
aviez identifié une quinzaine de lignes
et notamment sur l'île de france mais
pas que sur l'île de france puisque moi
en tant que sénateur d'eure et loir j'ai
une ligne à l'esprit qui est la ligne le
monde
chartres paris qui fonctionne pas encore
bien et je voudrais savoir depuis
à partir du moment où vous avez
identifié un certain nombre de lignes
quel est le résultat maintenant parce
que ça fait quand même un peu près un an
un an et demi maintenant et je veux
savoir où s'en était qu'elle avait été
vos décisions sur sur cela parce que je
ne constate pas pour l'instant c'était
après les lourds c'est normal il faut
aussi dire ce qui ne va pas je ne
constate pas beaucoup d'améliorations
fatah à vrai dire pas là monsieur le
président merci alors monsieur vincent
capo-canellas ce merci monsieur le
président d'abord monsieur le président
pépy on peut saluer votre parcours est
celui de la sncf et vous êtes sans doute
le mieux placé pour garder sncf sur de
bons rails
alors je crois d'ailleurs pas le
suspense était à son comble pour savoir
qui devait succéder à guillaume pepy a
par guillaume pepy et on peut selon peut
se réjouir de ce consensus
on vous attend peut-être moins et tout à
l'heure gérard cornu faisait allusion au
talent que vous avez et qu'on vous
reconnaît tous pour exposer clairement
la stratégie les intentions les
objectifs
on vous attend peut-être plus sûres
les résultats et sur un certain nombre
de clics et qu'il faudrait mettre pour y
parvenir
je crois que le cap est effectivement
bon la question c'est que en face le
confort du voyageur la satisfaction des
voyageurs
ça reste un enjeu qui est pas encore
bien traités vous avez abordé différents
sujets qui montre qu'il ya sans doute
des efforts mais on aimerait mieux
sentir quand même comment vous pouvez
crantée si j'ose dire les évolutions et
nous donner les points clés de tout cela
la donne et les principes auxquels on
peut souscrire sur la mobilisation
entreprises sur l'adhésion des salariés
sur la bonne utilisation de la réforme
de la gouvernance mais autour de ça on a
envie d'avoir des engagements un peu
plus chiffrée peut-être pour se rassurer
sur ce cap au delà des intentions
générales qu on partage tous je viens
sur deux ou trois questions michel
teston a posé quelques unes y en a mille
et unes qu'on pourrait poser un focus
sur l'île de france donné par
l'extérieur bon prémices a fait deux
annonces crois qu'on a progressé mais on
n'a pas résolu évidemment l'ensemble des
questions il en reste beaucoup encore
qui sont posées il ya aussi une
clarification qui s'amorce entre le stif
et la sgp semble-t-il
je crois que la sncf et transporteurs
elle n'est pas toujours décisionnaire
mais il n'est pas interdit me
semble-t-il à l'un des principaux
transporteurs les deux france de faire
des propositions là dessus est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire sous quelle forme
vous pouvez demain faire des
propositions pour qu'on fait en sorte de
7 ce magma de ce capharnaüm en ile de
france et on aimerait vraiment que vous
avez identifié objectif là aussi on
aimerait comprendre comment on peut le
traiter
sur l'efficacité globale de la sncf de
vue le risque dont c'est en gros de
faire jusque pour le fret
si on regarde pas sur l'efficacité quand
tu à l'ouverture à la concurrence
on va se trouver dans le dans le décor
là aussi quels objectifs en termes de
productivité pouvons nous avoir
ah bon la question du statut a été posé
bon je pense qu'il faut il faut être
prudent sur ce sujet là mais qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire sncf concrètement pour
aboutir aux objectifs et quelles données
financières vous pouvez demander là
dessus dernier point
je veux parler d'un instant de finances
il ya quand même la question de la dette
et elle est toujours effleuré quand on
parle de la réforme
comment aborder cette question de la
dette parce que ça va quand même être
abandonnée un principe clé et puis enfin
la semaine dernière des intempéries
quelles leçons en tirez-vous
merci monsieur jean jacques filleul
merci monsieur le président écoutez
monsieur le président en dépit moi j'ai
comme une collègue j'ai écouté votre
votre bilan et une livre vos projets
cela ne vous étonnera pas une nous
conviennent et les perspectives que vous
avez dressé me semble tout à fait
intéressante importante et elle maciste
entend-elle m'incite en tant que
parlementaire a accompagné le mouvement
qui est celui de 7,17 17e entreprises
françaises comme vous l'avez rappelé
tout honneur voilà donc c'est une
audition particulière moi je vous
apporterai aussi comme d'autres l'ont
dit ici mon soutien voilà total et parce
que je crois que vous êtes comme cela
arrive souvent
vous êtes celui qui participa à
l'évolution de cette grande maison
nous l'avons connu dans d'autres époques
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui
hélas quand même belle allure même s'ils
se pose énormément de questions
beaucoup des questions ont été évoquées
par michel teston brillamment je vous
j'ai pris autant de plaisir à vous
écouter qu'à écouter michel bon je le
dis et je le dis sans comme peut-être
vous même
d'ailleurs vous l'avez vous l'avez
ressenti mais je mais je le dis sans
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de plaisir
voilà en même temps se pose quand même
beaucoup de beaucoup de problèmes malgré
tout notre collègue capo-canellas a
parlé de la dette
elle est toujours présente dans le cadre
de la nouvelle gouvernance quelles sont
les perspectives que vous envisagez
nous en avions parlé je me souviens dans
une réunion sur ce point comme dans
quelles sont les perspectives que vous
envisagez pour réduire cette dette et
sur combien de quelles perspectives sur
le temps parce qu'elle pèse sur le
système ferroviaire français
autre problème aussi c'est l'évolution
de de la concurrence entre les
différentes compagnies ferroviaires
européennes
comment comment comment cela se passe
avec la db par exemple on cite souvent
l'exemple de la db par rapport à la
france
nous parlons tous du fret vous teen
movies et à l'instant que le ferait trop
présent à peu près 9 milliards sur les
34 milliards de chiffre d'affaires
mehal est à l'intérieur des 9 milliards
est ce qu'il n'ya que le fret
ferroviaire
ou est-ce qu'il ya le fret de geodis et
des autres sociétés de transport de la
multinationale sncf
et ça ça m'intéresse beaucoup mais je
crois que ça intéresse beaucoup de mes
collègues
vous avez parlé du fret il me semble que
c'est sans doute dans votre exposé le
point où nous avons beaucoup
d'interrogations je crois vraiment parce
qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de moyens pour
mettre en oeuvre un fret ferroviaire en
france et qui soient utiles
évidemment au transport des marchandises
qui ne représentent que 8 à 9 % des
marchandises transportées actuellement
et en même temps le fret est un outil
d'aménagement d'un aménagement du
territoire considérable dans la mesure
où nos concitoyens n'accepte plus et
vous savez même si la sncf est le
premier transporteur poids lourds de
france n'accepte plus les poids lourds
sur les routes donc beaucoup de
questions et bien d'autres et en
particulier comment résoudre ce problème
qui touche le fret évidemment de de la
mauvaise convergence sociale du cadre
social européen entre les et dire effet
les différentes sociétés qui
interviennent dans le transport on l'a
beaucoup d'autres questions
kan pourrait poser mais nous avez
compris vous avez toute ma confiance
dernier point monsieur le président
excusez moi je suis toujours inquiet sur
les conséquences de la lgv atlantique
rien n'est résolu et je me demande
comment les gares intermédiaires de
tours de poitiers d'angoulême vont être
servis à partir de 2017
merci robert navarro ensuite merci
monsieur le président monsieur pépy moi
je voulais déjà le dit malgré tout les
considérant que j'ai pour vous je ne
crois pas aux hommes aux femmes
providentiels je crois au dynamique de
groupe qui sommes en harmonie et je peux
témoigner depuis novembre notamment
région qu'au niveau national que vous
avez avec vous au niveau national au
niveau régional les meilleures équipes
du moment
ceci est une chance pour la sncf c'est
pour notre pays
mais comme beaucoup de secteurs vont
bien contrairement à ce que croient nos
collègues notamment au niveau de la
qualité du service voyageur est tournée
à des niveaux on peut jouer à la marge
mais globalement les services rendus au
public sont d'un très bon niveau
il ya deux secteurs qui doivent être
améliorés fondamentalement premièrement
c'est le fret
là nous sommes en dessous de nuls dont
il ya tout à faire
oui il faut se dire les vérités depuis
des années et sncf le fret ferroviaire
périclite
il n'y a pas de volonté qu'elles soient
politiques au niveau de la sncf ou de
l'état pour mettre un grand plan
d'ensemble pour mettre en place le fret
ferroviaire adaptée au besoin de
l'europe et de notre pays
donc quelles sont vos perspectives quels
sont les paliers parce que c'est un plan
sur mer avait mis 30 ans mais le fret
ferroviaire et la garantie d'un avenir
positif pour la sncf c'est là où nous
avons le maximum de marge de manoeuvre
de progression deuxièmement au niveau de
la gouvernance
moi j'ai connu une fonctionnement de la
sncf où il y avait une direction
centrale et bon nombre de directions
exploitation matériel et traction autres
actuellement on est dans une stratégie
où il ya une multitude de filières
cf plus personne n'y comprend rien
vingt-cinq son de cloche différent
plusieurs points de vue à prendre en
compte pour essayer d'aller de l'avant
donc je trouve que là vous avez un
efforts énormes à bousculer les choses
pour que entre rff gares et connexions
la sncf tout s'harmonise vers les mêmes
objectifs et que tout le monde ne
prennent en compte le fait que nous
sommes dans le même pays
dans la même entreprise et qu'on gagnera
le combat contre la concurrence dont il
ne faut pas avoir peur du moment nous
tous on mettra la même énergie pour
arriver le même bateau de voir les deux
angles d'attaqué moi qui me semblent les
plus en plus important le fret quel
avenir quel angle d'attaqué l'axiome
quelques progressions et la gouvernance
quelles sont les améliorations que vous
pouvez vous faire entrevoir merci
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le président pepy moi j'étais très
heureux d'entendre ce que vous avez dit
sur la capacité française à agir au
niveau international en tant que fils
d'un ingénieur à l'origine du tgv est
qui a passé sa vie avant d'être à des
métros dans le monde entier je me
réjouis évidemment de ce que vous avez
dit là et j'espère que ça va pouvoir se
poursuivre dans l'avenir pour revenir
ainsi nous concerne plus directement en
ile de france vous avez souligné le
retard considérable accumulées pendant
des années dans notre région c'est pas à
vous que je vais expliquer la difficulté
qui a relié paris depuis notre lointaine
banlieue et en particulier sur paris
saint lazare sur un certain nombre de
lignes qui sont archi saturé avec des
difficultés considérables mais je
voudrais savoir si vous avez des
indications précises sur les
tangentielles qui permettrait de
rejoindre de banlieue à banlieue je
pense en parler en particulier de cergy
pontoise à saint quentin en yvelines
versailles qui sera une tendance hier
extrêmement utile aujourd'hui et dont
malheureusement le nouveau grand paris
m'indique que peut-être j'aurai la
chance de pouvoir la voir arriver à
l'horizon 2027 2030 ce qui me fait franc
fonde aimant profondément pleurer de la
même manière comment dirais-je
j'entends que sur le fret ferroviaire
évidemment il ya énormément à faire je
suis d'accord avec ce qu'il vient de
dire robert navarro et moi je suis
partisan en plus d'une
comment dirais-je de d'interconnecter le
freeride il revient non seulement avec
la route mais aussi avec le fluvial
comme vous le savez à conflans on est
capital de la batellerie et les gens
j'ai appris par la presse locale que il
était envisagé à l'horizon 2020 de
relancer la ligne j qui viendrait
du havre pour rejoindre argenteuil en
passant par gisors et cergy pontoise et
conflans et nous nous faire passer des
trains de marchandises en pleine nuit de
manière tout à fait importante sur cette
ligne là alors sachant qu'il ya aucune
protection pour les riverains et qu' on
est déjà sinistré par les trappes et les
nuisances aériennes et par les nuisances
autoroutière j'aimerais savoir si
vraiment c'est dans les objectifs et
dans les perspectives de la sncf
j'aimerais avoir des garanties réussi
parce que inutile de vous dire que si
c'est le cas on va rentrer dans une
résistance extrêmement violente
merci merci alors dernière question
laurence rossignol
j'hésite un peu posé une question de
temps ça va être gros c'est de ma part
parce que je me sauvais tout après donc
c'était juste un petit sujet dans
l'homme dans la sacoche
je présente la sncf moi j'ai pas le
niveau de compétence de mes collègues
sont sncf du moins pas le niveau
théorique mais on est tous nous les élus
beaucoup des usagers mais surtout des
ambassadeurs quotidien on est un peu on
est tous un peu dans votre service de rp
parce que les gens nous nous interpelle
facilement sur les dysfonctionnements
elle et j'ai juste une chose je crois
qu'il ya quelques années la sncf a fait
procéder à une séparation des métiers et
qu'aboutir keats et de séparation de mes
discours destiné à mettre de la fluidité
et à faire évoluer les entreprises et
des fois elles aboutissent exactement à
des résultats inverses et on se retrouve
50 ans en arrière de l'autre côté du mur
un exemple tout simple la semaine
dernière beaucoup de perturbations bon
la neige tout ça tout ça tout le monde
comprend quand les voyageurs sont trois
quatre heures en pleine nuit sur un quai
et que le gars de d'aiguillage veut pas
les ouvrir la salle des pas perdus parce
que la séparation des métiers fait
qu'ils considèrent que c'est pas lui
d'alluré assad n'est pas perdu et que le
premier gars qui pourrait venir le faire
et à une heure et demie de voiture pas
ce qu'est ce que du verglas et qui
propose lui donner le code pour rentrer
et que le doivent pas le faire c'est
très compliqué d'expliquer aux usagers
que la séparation des métiers est une
bonne mesure de management de la sncf
mais qui va les laisser dehors pendant
trois heures toute la nuit juste le
président donc dans votre prochain
mandat parce que vous allez recueillir
une amie de limiter très grande dans
cette commission probablement la même à
l'assemblée nationale tout à l'heure si
vous pouviez réfléchir sur comment faire
la séparation des métiers tout en
mettant la fluidité et la souplesse
nécessaires c'est pas mal merci bien
monsieur le président vous le besoin de
respirer de boire un petit verre
l'enfermer lâché rude
non non non ajouté enfin les questions
de toute façon sont toujours qu'elle
soit vaste ou précisé sont toujours
révélatrices de choses intéressantes
avec l'autorisation des autres en vue en
intervenant je me propose de dire une
phrase sur l'interpellation de madame
rossignol je trouve cette interpellation
est une des raisons pour lesquelles
l'unification du système est aujourd'hui
nécessaire au fond ce que vous décrivez
c'est qu'on a mis d'un côté les
questions d'infrastructures et de
réseaux et de l'autre côté les questions
de service et de gares et étant donné
que les signaux qui sont données sont
interprétées par les cheminots qui sont
légitimistes
effectivement on aboutit à des
comportements complètement aberrant avec
le nouveau président de réseau ferré de
france qui est je crois qui a été
auditionnée par cette même commission
nous avons la ferme détermination que
dans le respect des règles européennes
qui sont d'ailleurs en cours
d'élaboration
donc il ne s'impose pas encore qui font
l'objet de discussions à bruxelles et
plus tard de discussions avec les
parlementaires européens dans le respect
de ces dispositions
nous souhaitons unifier le système pour
éviter ce type de dysfonctionnement qui
est totalement inexplicable mais à qui
que ce soit dans cette salle
donc je prends ce point là parce que ça
mérite aussi une petite réaction au
passage en disant qu' on va dire le
trouvons des mots polis pour dire que
les comportements trop rigide n'ont pas
besoin d'attendre une nouvelle loi pour
être combattue donc je prends votre
point très au sérieux
si je reviens en amont sur les
différentes questions qui ont été
soulevées pour apporter des éléments
d'information au sénat sur la dette la
dette de la sncf a baissé d'un milliard
d'euros en 2012 la question elle est
plutôt autour de la dette de réseau
ferré de france et demain de la dette
unifiée du système moi il me semble que
sans trahir le les intentions du
gouvernement il ya forcément deux étapes
la première étape c'est de stabiliser et
ensuite c'est de réduire la
stabilisation est un enjeu clé c'est un
peu la différence entre l'endettement et
surendettement être endetté pour
construire des lignes ou pour acheter
des trains ce n'est pas en soi un
problème
ce qui est embêtant c'est le
surendettement c'est à dire le fait que
pour payer le service de la dette il
faille se ré endetter ou que cette dette
augmente de façon mécanique année par
année donc avec le président de réseau
ferré de france
nous faisons en ce moment même des
propositions au gouvernement des
propositions de performance pour limiter
voire neutraliser l'augmentation de la
dette
cela supposera quand même que la
commission présidée par philippe duron
commission de révision du snit
aboutissent à on va dire un schéma
raisonnable sur le financement de
nouvelles infrastructures tgv
il est évident que notre pays ne peut
pas à la fois avoir un plan tgv accéléré
rattraper le retard en ile-de-france et
en même temps moderniser le réseau
classique les trois choses au même
moment sont extraordinairement difficile
et donc là il ya des choix ce n'est pas
la sncf à rff de l'est
c'est évidemment aux pouvoirs publics et
au parlement mais ça sera un point clé
sur l'évolution de la dette
deuxième question qui est posée à la
fois par monsieur testons et par
monsieur capo-canellas sacchi sur le
cadre social harmonisé au fond ce qui
est aujourd'hui un problème c'est que
coexistent sur le même réseau au même
moment dans les mêmes métiers ont font
deux régimes d'emplois différents le
régime d'emploi de l'ancienne entreprise
et le régime d'emploi des nouvelles
entreprises
outre le fait que les cheminots peuvent
pas comprendre qu'ils aient deux types
de règles qui s'appliquent aux mêmes
métiers au même moment sur le même
réseau ça crée évidemment pour
l'entreprise un dilemme difficile soit
l'entreprise s'aligne sur les coûts du
privé et elle vend à perte
soit l'entreprise reflète la vérité de
ses coûts et elle perd le marché et donc
c'est une distorsion qui suppose mais
heureusement on a beaucoup avancé ces
derniers mois que tout le monde se mette
autour de la table le patronat public et
privé les syndicats pour se dire quel
est le pacte social quel est le contrat
social du 21e siècle qu'on souhaite pour
le secteur ferroviaire et qui sera un
contrat social négocié moi j'ai
l'habitude de dire aux cheminots il ya
dans notre pays 600 conventions
collectives
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on va être là
601e et que si on a réussi six cent fois
dans notre pays à négocier une
convention collective n'y a pas
tellement de raison qu'on ne réussisse
pas une 601e fois ça prend du temps ça
peut être compliqué mais le principe de
la convention collective c'est le
principe de règles qui s'appliquent à
toutes les entreprises tout et qui sont
des règles d'un point d'équilibré entre
les patrons et les syndicats
et c'est le projet que je porte et la
bonne nouvelle que je peux indiquer
aujourd'hui au sénat c'est que je pense
que l'opinion cheminote les
organisations syndicales sont
extrêmement responsables sur cette
question elles savent que l'avenir du
système ferroviaire repose pour partie
dans la négociation d'un cadre social
moderne et de haut niveau pour le
système ferroviaire sur les trains
d'équilibré du territoire il ya une
bonne nouvelle
c'est que dans le cadre du projet de loi
de finances vous avez doter le
renouvellement du matériel roulant
d'environ 400 millions d'euros et que
donc nous allons pouvoir engager le
changement des trains corail vers d'être
un nouveau ça prendra du temps parce
qu'il ya forcément de l'ordre d'un
millier de rames qui pourraient être
changées
donc cela prendra plusieurs années il
faut se décider et choisir une fabrique
et mais le mouvement est engagé et de
surcroît comme je l'avais indiqué
lorsque le ministre des transports frais
des cuviers nous a interpellé sur les
grandes lignes que constitue le pari
clairement où le paris orléans limoges
toulouse
nous lui avons fait la proposition
d'introduire sur ces lignes qui sont les
fameuses lignes du capitole du volcan
des lignes dans lequel il y avait des
trains 200 km nous avons fait la
proposition d'introduire du matériel tgv
à défaut d'avoir aujourd'hui même la
ligne qui a de bien meilleures
caractéristiques de confort et d et de
services donc c'est la proposition que
nous avons faite à frédéric cuvillier
qui est l'autorité organisatrice sur les
trois questions pour être rapide de
monsieur grignon sécurité oui c'est un
vrai sujet les incidents de grigny de ce
weekend relève de la police nationale ce
sont des délits et donc en tant qu
entreprise ferroviaire nous pouvons
faire de la prévention
mais nous ne sommes ni la police ni la
justice cela dit nous avons aujourd'hui
2500 cheminots qui a 100 % exercent des
fonctions de prévention et de présence
donc la surveillance générale nous
achevons en 2015 le programme de
vidéoprotection qui avaient été décidés
il y a quatre ans nous aurons à l'époque
24000 25 mille caméras y compris dans
les trains moitié dans les trains moitié
dans les gares et le programme de
vidéoprotection c'est un problème de
dissuasion sur les actes délictueux et
enfin comme vous l'avez sans doute
constaté
nous développons l'accueil embarquement
c'est à dire les opérations au sol qui
vise à vérifier que ceux qui montent à
bord ont un billet et non pas pour
objectif de commettre des actes d
que sur l'avenir du modèle tgv là encore
je m'en remets à la sagesse des travaux
trans travées de la commission du rond
il ya quatre lignes à grande vitesse en
construction elles seront toutes
inauguré entre 2017 et 2018
au delà la commission dure on examine
les critères qui doivent être ceux des
futures lignes a décidé j'assiste auprès
de vous sur le fait qu' il me semble que
la priorité absolue doit aller au réseau
existant à son entretien et à
l'amélioration des lignes qui sont
aujourd'hui les plus en difficulté avec
des ralentissements les lignes saturées
ou les lignes qui ne sont pas
suffisamment robustes enfin sur la
transparence vous l'avez dit j'ai pris
des engagements vis-à-vis des présidents
de région un décompte par ligne 2 un
rapport du délégataire comme dans les
services urbains et 3 des tableaux de
bord mensuels pour que les élus puissent
peser le coût et les bénéfices de
chacune des lignes et ne chacun des
services qu'ils développent sur la
question posée par madame masson maret
qui portait sur les risques
psychosociaux je vous dire qu'on partage
totalement votre appréciation c'est à
dire que c'est un sujet d'une extrême
sensibilité
la société d'aujourd'hui la crise tout
ça c'est dur les risques psycho sociaux
existent on prend ces affaires là
extrêmement sérieux on les traite par
des accords d'entreprise avec les
organisations syndicales par la
formation de nos managers et
heureusement par l'existence d'une
médecine du travail qui est une médecine
interne à l'entreprise et qui permet que
les situations de fragilité ou de risque
soit apprécié de façon très proche des
salariés et pour ce qui me concerne
c'est une préoccupation quotidienne
qu'il n'y ait pas de passage à l'acte et
que nous ne soyons pas devant des
catastrophes humaines qui ensuite
rejaillissent sur tout le code le corps
social
en écho à ce que disait monsieur gérard
cornu deux questions les qu'est ce qu'on
appelle les conditions de concurrence
loyale et puis les lignes fragile
conditions de concurrence ouaya je le
disais nous comme entreprise ferroviaire
historique l'ancien monopole
nous devons accepter que la concurrence
viendra c'est au parlement européen et
au parlement français d'en décider mais
ça viendra et vous en fixerait la date
et vous n'en fixera les modalités
notre travail c'est de préparer
l'entreprise qu'elles soient en état de
gagner j'espère ou parfois de perdre des
appels d'offres mais pour cela il ya une
règle absolue il faut que ont cours
entre guillemets la future compétition
avec les mêmes règles
je cite deux exemples d'abord le cadre
social harmonisé on en a suffisamment
parlé le cadre social harmonisé c'est la
garantie que les cheminots public et les
cheminots privé où les cheminots public
français les cheminots publics allemands
espagnols ou italiens auront les mêmes
règles sociales par exemple la même
amplitude de travail les mêmes taquet le
même nombre de jours de repos pour que
au fond chacun puisse faire valoir ben
la qualité de service la robustesse est
bon et la deuxième chose c'est
qu'évidemment les régimes fiscaux et
légaux soient les mêmes typiquement nous
avons nous un taux de cotisation
retraite qui est d'une dizaine de points
supérieur à celui des autres entreprises
il faudra traiter ce sujet là pour que
la sncf ne soit pas dans une situation
de pénalisation dans les futurs appels
d'offres sur les lignes sensibles
il ya du bon et il ya du moins bon on
avait identifié une douzaine de lignes
qui étaient fragiles je peux vous
indiquer que sur huit ou neuf nous
sommes sortis d'affaires mais il en
reste trois ou quatre sur lequel nous ne
sommes pas sortis d'affairé il faut
remettre le travail sur le métier
les lignes où nous n'avons pas terminé
le travail c'est paris clermont c'est
paris orléans limoges toulouse c'est
paris amiens boulogne et à certains
égards paris chartres le mans comme
monsieur cornu l'a souligné le matériel
est très ancien sur paris chartres le
mans il va heureusement être nous
et on va donc pouvoir faire un meilleur
travail dans les années à venir mais je
considère pas que le travail ce que le
service soit à la hauteur des attentes
monsieur capo-canellas ce m'interpellait
sûr concrètement quels sont les trois
quatre leviers pour améliorer le service
aux voyageurs je les cite un peu dans
l'ordre d'importance le premier c'est
l'arrivée de matériel neuf
la bonne nouvelle en france c'est que
sans doute d'ici la fin de la décennie
nous serons proches de 100% de matériel
ferroviaire neufs ou rénovés en france
proche
ça c'est quand même une nouvelle
formidable ça a été un investissement
des collectivités qui est tout à fait
gigantesque je citais le chiffre de 7
milliards pour les régions s'est pas
terminée puisque nous avons en commande
un millier de trains supplémentaires 9
le deuxième facteur c'est la notion des
gars on avait pris un très grand retard
qu'on est en train de combler il ya
vingt projets majeurs qui sont en cours
en france de rénovation de gares le
troisième sujet c'est la modernisation
des voies
nous terminons actuellement ce qui
s'appelait le plan perben qui a couvert
la période 2009 2015 et le gouvernement
frédéric cuvillier nous a demandé de
faire des prévisions nouvelles pour la
période 2015 2020
toujours pour moderniser le réseau
existant nous sommes en train d'y
travailler avec jacques rapoport
et enfin concernant spécialement l'île
de france
moi je crois à deux choses la fin de la
guerre stupide ratp sncf avec pierre
mongin depuis maintenant quatre ou cinq
ans nous avons décidé d'unifier
progressivement la gestion de nos lignes
communes cette année en 2013 nous allons
unifier la gestion de la ligne b
nord-sud et il nous restera la ligne a
est ouest et puis deuxièmement grâce à
la réforme du système ferroviaire en ile
de france on va rapprocher les questions
d'infrastructures et des questions de
service et nous allons pouvoir dans
quelques jours annoncé je pense que le
le miz des transports le fera lui-même
une organisation beaucoup plus intégrée
en ile-de-france entre les voies et les
trains sur les questions soulevées par
monsieur filleul ge sur le fret
d'ailleurs madame rossignol y est
revenue et monsieur navarro aussi il me
semble que comme monsieur navarro nous y
incitait c'est à dire si on veut prendre
la profondeur
si on veut faire davantage de fret
ferroviaire en europe de l'ouest il ya
trois décisions lourdes à prendre la
première c'est de trouver entre la route
et le rail la zone de pertinence de
chacun ma proposition ça serait de dire
la courte distance à la route
en l'acceptant mais la contrepartie
c'est qu'il faut que les chargeurs et
les routiers accepte que les longues
distances le transit européen
les très longues distances choix du
ressort du rail des pays l'ont fait
l'autriche par exemple interdit le
transit des camions sur son territoire
quand vous arrivez aux frontière de
l'autriche et que vous ne desservait pas
l'autriche
vous êtes obligé de mettre un canot sur
le train le résultat c'est une décision
qu'ils ont pris il ya 30 ans le résultat
c'est qu'il ya 38 % de part de marché
qui est fait par le rail en autriche
et pourtant c'est un pays libéral avec
une économie de marché mais ils ont pris
des décisions en responsabilité la
deuxième condition pour réussir c'est de
réserver une partie des investissements
ou transport de marchandises là dessus
il ya ce qui s'appelle dans notre jargon
un plan borloo qui avait été adoptée en
2008 avec 7 milliards d'euros
d'investissements réservé au fret
ferroviaire se planche mais en oeuvre
progressivement ils comportent par
exemple un contournement fret de
l'agglomération lyonnaise qui permettra
aux trains de fret n'ont pas de passé
entre part-dieu et perrache et aux
trains de fret de suivre comme
l'autoroute et de pouvoir éviter de
passer par le centre de l'agglomération
enfin si on veut réellement faire du
fret ferroviaire il faudra un jour
abordé à l'échelle européenne
la contradiction entre la dérégulation
sociale de la route et lippert
régulation sociale du ferroviaire
c'est sensible mais si on n'abandonne
pas cette question
deux modes concurrents avec un mode
hyper régulier et un mode hyper dérégulé
on risque d'être déçu sur le long terme
je voudrais faire écho à ce que disait
monsieur monsieur philippe esnol sûr au
fond les deux questions va-t-on voir des
trains de fret circuler sur la
tangentielle ouest
ma conviction est que non cette décision
a été prise il ya maintenant une
quinzaine d'années ne pas mettre de
trains fret sur la la tangentielle ouest
je ne pense pas qu'elle soit remise en
cause
en revanche nous sommes en train de
travailler à une desserte ferroviaire du
port du havre et du port de rouen qui
malheureusement était des porcs dans
lequel l'essentiel du trafic était fait
par la route donc électrification
modernisation et l'électrification
serqueux gisors qui ai commencé qui
devra se poursuivre pour qu'il y ait un
axe fret qui permettent de desservir les
ports normands sans passer par la ligne
paris vous voyez la ligne voyageurs
paris rouen le havre et en ayant un
itinéraire fret
enfin sur la question soulevée par
madame rossignol je pense y avoir
répondu je veux simplement redire que
parmi les problèmes prioritaires
il y as pour nous les trains du grand
bassin parisien
donc la desserte de l'oise de l'eure et
loir la desserte évidemment de la
picardie la desserte du centre avec des
navetteurs qui font parfois des trajets
très long ces trains là sont une
priorité de modernisation car nos
usagers font souvent une heure une heure
et quart de trajet aller et retour dans
des conditions qui sont pas celles qui
sont en droit d'attendre
je voudrais terminer juste par un mot
sur l'intervention de michel teston pour
lui dire que sur la réforme qui
non ce nous nous sommes conscients de
notre responsabilité c'est à dire que la
france est en train de construire son
propre modèle de système ferroviaire ou
plutôt de tirer les enseignements de ce
qui s'est passé ces quinze dernières
années qui n'est pas que négatif mais
qui n'a pas totalement rempli les
aspirations et donc nous sommes en train
de construire un modèle à la française
pour le système ferroviaire
c'est pour l'entreprise dont je vais
avoir peut-être la responsabilité une
response historique d'avoir un système
ferroviaire français construit en france
et non pas selon des normes souvent très
bureaucratiques ou très théorique qui
ont été conçus et ailleurs
si cette chance nous est donné ça sera
aussi notre responsabilité d'être à la
hauteur de cette confiance
la réunification qui est envisagé c'est
au fond dire à la famille cheminote vous
êtes un et un seul métier et le pays
vous fait confiance et le pays vous
donne de la visibilité
la contrepartie de cette confiance c'est
la performance c'est le saut de
performance que nous allons devoir faire
qualité de service efficacité économique
sens du client sens du service public et
moi c'est le sens du mandat que que
j'espère recevoir dans les jours et les
semaines à venir
merci monsieur le président je crois que
vous avez répondu je pense à toutes les
questions nombreuses et pertinentes
critique mais justifiée je pense que
j'avais pu certainement percevoir
je pense que là le respect et la
considération de la plupart de mes
collègues face à ce que vous avez fait
et aussi certainement j'espère tout à
l'heure leur expression de leur
confiance pour le futur
voilà tout cas merci et donc comme le
veut s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
la procédure je vais vous raccompagner
ils vont passer au vote
à moins que vous ayez dernier vous eu le
dernier mot je ne sais pas si dans la
tradition de ces auditions ça peut se
faire mais je vous remercie au nom de
des 250000 de salariés de l'entreprise
de de vos encouragements et de vos
appréciations et je pense que les
messages que vous nous avez passé seront
très très positivement entendu je vous
remercie
voilà pour l'audition de guillaume pepy
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
qui reçoit ce soir le député ump de
l'aisne à xavier bertrand